this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain a
website an online store making with
Squarespace check out Squarespace calm
for a free trial link below and let's
get into it Charles Ponzi Bernie Madoff
Billy fire festival McFarland's history
is littered with the misdeeds of
Kahneman who pulls the wool over the
public's eyes and made a killing some
like Frank Abagnale the model for
Leonardo DiCaprio's character and catch
me if you can
pulled off cons so big as they've become
legendary but not even Abagnale could
compete with our subject today gregor
McGregor was many things soldier pirate
pathological liar he was also the man
who pulled off the biggest con in
history in 1821 McGregor arrived in
London with tall tales of a new Latin
American nation where fortunes could be
made using his deadly charm McGregor
managed to not only swindle banks
investors and ordinary people out of the
19th century equivalents of billions of
pounds he indulged in fabrications on
such a colossal scale that even Europe's
governments were fools but how did this
Scottish nobody create a con so big it
swallowed an entire continent
well join us today as we explore the
life of Gregor McGregor the most immoral
adventurer to ever live
[Music]
when he came to tell the story of his
birth many years later Gregor McGregor
would never let two details remain the
same he was born in Tsar High Scottish
nobility he was descended from a
legendary outlaw Rob Roy his ancestors
were adventurers who founded Scotland's
doomed colony in the Darien Gap the odd
thing was he needn't have bothered
Gregor McGregor's backgrounds was
interesting enough even without his tall
tales born on Christmas Eve 1786
McGregor came from well the MacGregors
Jacobite plan that had only just been
real eagle-eyes daftar a hundred years
as outlaws while his dad wasn't the
chief as McGregor would claim his family
were still notable his grandpa had been
an officer and what would become the
Black Watch his father was a ship
chaplain in short young McGregor had
action in his blood and in 1803 when
McGregor was only 16 that blood would
drive him to seek adventure in the
British Army as I could have it 1803 was
the year that the Napoleonic Wars broke
out and McGregor was hurriedly posted to
the island of Guernsey to defend against
French invasion but that invasion never
came instead McGregor wound up living a
deeply unadventurous live verb just
waiting around not that his time on
Guernsey was a total waste
it was while on assignment that McGregor
met his first wife Maria Bowater was the
sort of catch young enlisted men used to
dream about her father was an admiral
her family members were mp's oh and they
were absolutely stinking rich in no time
at all McGregor had charmed his way into
marrying her much to the horror of her
family no sooner they tied the knots
than McGregor was using his wife's money
to buy himself the rank of captain and
get transferred down to Gibraltar
but while the weather may have been
nicer on Spain's southern tip life was
still boring for the next four years
McGregor did nothing but stand around
waiting for a French fleet that never
came then in 1809 just as McGregor was
planning to give up and return to
Scotland excitement finally arrived the
year before Napoleon had invaded Spain
engulfing the whole of Iberia in the
Peninsular war sensing a chance to give
Napoleon a black eye the British
decided to intervene and that's how
mcgregor founds himself in portugal
fighting Napoleon's forces yes even in
the heat of combat McGregor couldn't
settle in October he sold the rank of
captain and departed the British Army
for the Portuguese one but by May of
1810 it also got bored of the Portuguese
and he resigned again come summer 1810
mcgregor was back in scotland feeling
unfulfilled as ever but he was no longer
Mille Gregor McGregor on leaving the
Portuguese army McGregor had started
telling people had been knighted for his
service and was now sir McGregor it was
a stupid lie
done the Gatiss tikal little lie that
really shouldn't have changed anything
yes change things it did when people
didn't question it mcgregor realized
just how easy lying about even huge
things really was it was a revelation
that would soon take the young man to
some very bizarre places
[Music]
in April 1812 a ship pulled into port
near Caracas Venezuela and disgorged a
slender Scot in his mid-20s it had been
two years since MacGregor had left
Portugal disillusions and much of
happens in 1811 his wife had died and
his in-laws had cut him off financially
so MacGregor had left Britain in search
of something anything that would keep
his mind occupied
luckily 1811 wasn't short of
opportunities for a would-be adventurer
that year Venezuela had declared
independence from Spain kick-starting
the South American Wars of Independence
so MacGregor had decided to get involved
no sooner had he landed than the then
Republican leader Francisco de Miranda
had appointed him a cavalry officer
that's it would be an even bigger name
in Caracas society that MacGregor would
soon get involved with thanks to his
1812 marriage to Josefa Antonia Andrea
eres de ater ela vera
Josefa you see was none other than the
cousin of Simon Bolivar
well this newfound connection would
immediately work out well for MacGregor
just months after his marriage MacGregor
who was in flight running for safety as
the first Venezuelan Republic fell to
Spanish forces Francisco de Miranda was
captured while both McGregor and Bolivar
only escaped heading in opposite
directions by the skin of their teeth
and so began the period of Greger
McGregor's life where he kept crossing
paths with the greatest figures in Latin
American history only for it all to keep
going well horribly pear-shaped in 1813
for example McGregor volunteered in the
new Grenada army only to be assigned to
a remote border town and miss bolivars
admirable campaign and founding of the
second Venezuelan Republic in 1814 the
two both wound up in Cartagena or after
the Second Republic fell but Bolivar was
forced into exile while MacGregor got
trapped in the siege of the city finally
McGregor reconnected with Bulevar in
Haiti in early 1816 and joined his
latest campaign this was a campaign that
would nearly cost McGregor his life by
now most of Venezuela was back under
royalist control bolivars plan was plans
men at strategic points along the coast
then coordinate and mass uprising but in
charge of 600 troops MacGregor was
quietly dropped at a khmer unfortunately
the plan in
Stanley fell apart Bolivar was forced
into retreat and MacGregor and his men
were left standing on the shore their
mouths dangling open as their ride
disappeared
they were trapped in Riley's territory
over 300 kilometers from the nearest
Republican stronghold
they had no boots limited ammunition
even more limited provisions and they
were surrounded by swamp lands at that
moment it must have seemed to the 600
men like death was gonna be a certainty
they hadn't counted on McGregor's talent
for self-preservation though in a
remarkable feat of leadership McGregor
led his man on a march right through
royalist territory executing innumerable
brilliant maneuvers to keep the enemy at
bay it tricked the Spanish troops into
walking into swamp sea had his men
charged blockades on fur tons punched
right through it was like watching
LeBron James lead Elmer Fudd arounds
basketball court with the dim-witted
Royalists fumbling every play while
MacGregor around circles around them
laughing and yes as far as we know we
are the only youtube channel delivering
history via Space Jam to analogies
you're very welcome
after weeks of running battles MacGregor
finally led his men into the safety of a
Republican town when news leaked of his
300 kilometer track the Republican camps
exploded MacGregor became a hero
overnight his names celebrated across
the continent suddenly everyone wanted
to serve under him the guy who'd married
into bolivars family and then Boulevard
Boulevard but sadly this isn't a video
about Craig MacGregor revolutionary
general it's a video about Gregor
MacGregor
conman extraordinaire those soldiers all
clamoring to serve under him didn't know
it yet but MacGregor would soon lead
countless of their number into early
graves
in the wake of McGregor's daring escape
from Achmed Bolivar personally awarded
him the order of Liberty Torres
hopefully while shuffling rather
awkwardly and maybe mumbling something
about being sorry for abandoning him
but McGregor was disappointed he hadn't
gone through well to just get a shiny
new medal no he wanted a promotion a
race something to show the world that he
was a hero
if Hawk Amer wasn't enough for his
cousin in law McGregor would just have
to go one bigger that fall mercenaries
up in Pittsburgh began to whisper about
a Scottish man doing the rounds hiring
people for a private invasion of Spanish
Florida the Scot was a Portuguese Knight
a Venezuelan hero more to the point it
was very generous anyone who joins him
was being given titles to huge estates
in Florida for the rough-and-tumble men
of Pittsburgh's dive bars this seemed
like a no brainer which is how in June
1817 McGregor was able to sail for
Amelia Island Florida at the head of 200
mercenaries there was just one minor
catch McGregor didn't actually own the
lands that had been dishing out to his
private army but I mean why spoil a good
invasion with that right not when
everything was just going so well and he
really was when the Spanish garrison on
the island saw all these armed Americans
they assumed it was the head of a
full-blown US force and they surrendered
now all mcgregor needed to do was press
his advantage take a few more forts and
it soon have another victory to rival
ahkamat but that didn't happen
instead McGregor declared Amelia Islands
the Republic of East Florida and then
simply settled into enjoyed getting
drunk and sunning himself for McGregor's
men this was a bit a bit of a doot what
moments but then he started paying them
in Republic of East Florida dollars and
well it made no difference whatsoever
finally one morning in September the
mercenaries awoke to find McGregor had
taken the ship and the remaining money
and simply say all the way leaving them
to their fates at that point they
probably couldn't even summon a squeak
of surprise to show how they felt
following the Florida failure McGregor
badly fell out of favor with Bolivar so
he tried again in 1818 McGregor sailed
back to Britain hired some 500 more
this time he tried to conquer Panama
landing a force of 200 at Portobello he
took the city and then he went straight
back to lounging around in the Sun
drinking rum and failing to do anything
that might stave off a potential Spanish
counter-attack the last bit proved
importance when the potential
counter-attack became an actual counter
attack and McGregor was forced to flee
once again leaving his mercenaries to
their fates
by now the Scot was starting to look
less like the capable general of Arkham
Mayer and more like a shallow egotist
who just so happened to get a bit lucky
but his name still carried enough shine
for McGregor surviving men to follow him
on one last invasion in October 1819
McGregor landed outside a royalist hold
out on Venezuela's coast it was the
exact same checklist as Amelia islands
in Portobello McGregor
takes a city absolutely McGregor gets
drunk rather than organizing defences
absolutely when things go south McGregor
sails away and leaves his men to their
fates absolutely this time though his
fates were particularly gruesome after
the Spanish retook the city they lined
up all of McGregor surviving mercenaries
and had them shot in the aftermath of
McGregor's 3rd colossal screw-ups Simon
Bolivar didn't so much throw the book at
him as crush him beneath an entire
library of disapproval Bulevar declared
his cousin and Laura traitor he issued a
decree that any Venezuelan who saw
McGregor should kill him on sight but
while this was the end of McGregor's
time is a revolutionary warrior
it wasn't the ends of the man himself
when he resurfaced it was going to be
with a con that would go down in history
now just before we get into that
incredible story I'd love to take a
minute to tell you about today's sponsor
Squarespace Squarespace allows you to
create a powerful online identity maybe
you've taken over a country and you need
a website for that new country or you
know maybe not either way Squarespace is
how you should go about setting up your
online presence it all starts on
Squarespace with a beautiful template
and they come with requisite cool names
like Pursuit and Royce you can meet the
star from scratch or easily move over an
existing domain making everything super
easy to manage and once you've gone
through the easy customization process
there's no updates there's no patches
has no tech be us to deal with no one
likes tech BS you know what everyone
does like Squarespace is 24/7 customer
support there to help you why never
you've got a question and Squarespace
isn't just about an online presence you
can totally sell stuff or services on a
Squarespace site look if you're looking
to start a business pursue a dream take
over a country do it with Squarespace
look if you're looking to start a
business pursue a dream etc do it with
Squarespace at squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash biographic sand save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and let's get back to the con sprawling
along the Caribbean coasts of modern-day
Nicaragua and Honduras the mosquito Shah
is exactly as unappetizing as its name
suggests it's hot it's wet its desolate
it's where life is cheap diseases rife
and mosquitoes are omnipresent in April
1820 gregor mcgregor hopped off a boat
and vanished into the mangrove forests
of this tropical Hell desperate to lose
himself by now it wasn't just Bolivar he
wanted him dead the Spanish the
Americans the British all for varying
reasons they had McGregor's name on a
hit list in the movie of McGregor's life
this would be the low point to the point
where all seems lost but you know what
always comes after the low point in any
movie scripts the pass where the hero
triumphs while hiding on the mosquito
sure MacGregor came into contact with
one of the local tribal leaders a guy
who styled himself as King George
Frederick Augustus being a natural
charmer McGregor got the guy drunk and
spent a few days partying with him by
the time he emerged from the King's
heart weary and hungover McGregor was
clutching a title deed to eight million
acres of tribal lands this piece of
paper would become the basis for his
audacious next move back in McGregor's
native britain the nation was gearing up
for the coronation of George the fourth
there were street parties dignitaries
from all over the world in fact there
were so many dignitaries that no one
noticed when one arrived from a country
that didn't exist his serene Highness
Gregor MacGregor the first sovereign
Prince of the state
paiace in its dependencies and Cacique
of the pyre nation arrived in london in
summer of 1821 just like with
MacGregor's fake knighted in 1810 no one
questioned his absurd new title to
understand why you have to remember when
the story is set in 1821 a whole bunch
of new nations have just exploded into
existence Mexico Gran Colombia Argentina
Chile Paraguay Peru the London is it
wasn't much of a stretch to believe that
place might be among them especially
when the paiace envoi was related by
marriage suits women freakin Bolivar but
McGregor did more than just trade on his
connections to fool people under the
pseudonym Thomas Strangeways he
published a guidebook to poiice
detailing the nation's government its
geography its climate its architecture
this was serious imagination something
Tolkien would have been proud to write
and it was shot through with a glimpse
at a utopia that was the soil so fertile
it could support three harvests a year
there were the riverbeds we're lumps of
gold today among the banks there was the
fact that uniquely for Central America
boys had no tropical diseases and trust
us that last one will soon seem bitterly
ironic well I did McGregor go to all of
this trouble to invent a fake country
for an answer to that you need to look
to London Scottish communities that same
summer the place n boy began visiting
them he was offering them an opportunity
he said an opportunity not just to
better their own lives by moving to
paiace but an opportunity to establish
Scotland's first viable colony a chance
to make their country into a global
player all they had to do gregor
McGregor told his fellow Scots was to
buy one of these plots of poies lands
that he was selling fertile lands that
would set them up for life faced with
such an offer who could refuse by the
fall of 1822 interest in paiace was
running rampant the first boatload of
Scottish settlers have just departed for
the country and a general bubble in
Latin American securities was expanding
so when McGregor asked a bank to
underwrite ways bonds they simply nodded
and handed him two hundred thousand
pounds using that money McGregor opened
paiace consulates across Britain adding
to the schemes veneer of
Missy from aggregor these were the salad
days phrase which means the heyday of
something which is an odd choice when
you consider how boring salad is by
Windsor investment in boys bonds have
generated over a billion pounds in
today's money and McGregor was still
selling land to the gullible Scots the
second boat of settlers departed in
January 1823 but there's one problem
with dispatching boatloads of settlers
to a non-existent country what do they
do when they finally arrive well let's
find out
in November 1822 the first ship reached
a mosquito shore as the boat approached
land the Scottish settlers all donned
their fanciest outfits and fired the gun
so a pieace boat would come out and
guide them to the capital instead the
gunshot echoed across the empty waters
and mangrove swamps answered only by
deafening silence at first the settlers
assumes they must have made a navigation
error so they had their stuff unloaded
onto a deserted stretch of coast and
sent the captain off to find paiace it's
worth noting that these were not young
hardy types desperate for adventure most
of those caught up in the play scheme
were older folks looking for an easy
retirement or families with young
children so I think on a deserted
stretch of tropical shore was definitely
not within their skill set in March 1823
the second ship joined the stranded
settlers incredibly everyone just
assumes that the navigation was off even
when the captain of the first ship
returned and said so I've sailed up and
down this coast and there is no boy ace
they told him dude obviously there is go
try again please so the captain set off
again and now the hundred strong crowd
of settlers settled down to wait again
that same month the hurricane battered
the mosquito shore destroying supplies
and racking the remaining ship then the
rains came thick heavy endless rains
that left the settlers soaked finally in
the wake of the rains came the
mosquitoes if you've ever been to the
tropics in rainy season you're have seen
just how thick the air can get with
mosquitoes carrying things like yellow
fever and malaria on the deserted shore
the insects mobbed the unprepared
settlers biting them and infecting them
one by one the abandoned Scots began to
die
babies passed away in their mother's
arms elderly women died wracked with
malaria
of the 200 also paiace settlers who
reached the mosquito shore it's
estimated over two-thirds were killed by
tropical diseases it was a massacre by
neglect a death sentence just as sure as
a firing squad
the only reason anyone survived is
because a ship from British Honduras
just happened to pass by and alert the
colonial authorities for the rest of
1823 they're all Navy was overwhelmed
evacuating the survivors and
intercepting ships headed for paiace by
the year's end that stopped five more
settler ships each carrying hundreds of
people had they reached the mosquito
sure it's likely the death toll of the
paiace scheme would have topped 2,000
back in London news of the disaster
first broke in October of 1823
immediately lots of very angry people
began looking for places charming envoi
but they were too late
McGregor had fled England's just before
the story arrived taking as much of his
ill-gotten cash as he could carry it was
a horrific dinner more to the wildest
con ever pulls unbelievably though it
still was an over Gregor McGregor
wouldn't be done with a pie a scheme for
another 15 years
[Music]
from 1823 to 1838 McGregor pulled his
pious con again and again incredibly he
never faced any serious punishment for
it even after the harrowing tale of the
survivors got out no one in Europe could
accept poiice didn't exist McGregor had
simply lied too big in the same way our
brains wouldn't be able to process the
revelation that say Hawaii wasn't real
people in the 1820s just couldn't
comprehend the idea that place was
fictional when McGregor settled in Paris
the French governments even made him an
advisor on latin-american affairs this
despite McGregor restarting his fake
bond scheme in France although the
scheme itself was busted in 1825
McGregor successfully blamed his French
partners and again he got away scot-free
even returns a London and got more bonds
underwritten for eight hundred thousand
pounds while no investors bit this time
it wasn't because of the tragedy of the
mosquito sure it was because the Latin
American securities bubble had just
burst and no one wanted to risk another
for the next few years McGregor hocked
his scheme up and down Britain while he
never again hit the big time he always
had just enough money coming in to keep
the fiction going to keep people
believing in paiace finally in 1838
McGregor's wife Josef had died suddenly
alone in gloomy Britain the con man
seems to have at last given up on his
con that October McGregor got on a boat
and sailed back to Caracas he never
mentions paiace again so this is the
moment right this is finally the moment
when McGregor gets his comeuppance I
mean he's headed back to Venezuela at
the very place Simon Bolivar left orders
that he be killed on sight now if you're
hoping for a moral into this story it's
best to just switch this off now and
construct a wonderful fiction in your
head you see Bolivar a died all the way
back in 1830 by which time he was
incredibly unpopular with bolivars name
now mud everyone was kind of like do we
really need to kill the rounded Scottish
guy so they let me Gregor Lance they
even let him request an audience with
the government at which point Lady Luck
dropped an utterly undeserved gold
nugget right into McGregor's lap
remember akhom mare that one time
mcgregor actually acted like an arrow
well general carlos ablated it had been
under McGregor's command during that
mission and seen the conman
best since it never followed McGregor to
Florida reported Baloo or even heard of
paiace he had no idea of McGregor's true
character and now Sublette a was a
member of Venezuelans government when he
saw McGregor he basically let out a cry
and threw his arms around him that was
how in 1838 Venezuela came to reinstate
Gregor McGregor's ranked in its army and
over 25 years of back-pay and given a
generous pension for the next seven
years McGregor lived in Caracas wealthy
happy and respected by all he finally
died a peaceful death on December the
4th 1845 without ever having repented
for any of his cons sometimes life
really is just that unfair today it's
estimated that between the paiace scheme
and all the times he abandoned his men
Gregor McGregor was responsible for the
deaths of 500 people yes even though he
never got his comeuppance his story
offers us all excellent moral lessons
it's easy to fall into the trap of
assuming that the world is fair that
maybe bad things sometimes happen but in
the end everything will balance out the
tale of Gregor McGregor it laughs in the
face of this here was a man who treated
other people as disposable trash only
there to fuel his own fantasies a man
who sacrificed literally hundreds of
lives to the god of his ego and he never
tasted justice for even a single second
unique among figures we've covered
Gregor McGregor offers us a bleak but a
necessary warning sometimes good doesn't
triumph sometimes the happy wealthy
respected people are the ones who have
caused untold suffering Gregor McGregor
may be long dead but there will always
be others out there like him charming
and amoral if his life shows us anything
it's that we should always be on the
lookout for these people even when they
seem to be the most respectable types
you could ever hope to meet
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below also do
check out our wonderful sponsor
Squarespace who make these videos
possible and as always I'll see you next
time
[Music]